So here we were given a version of a JavaScript
interpreter that has a bug already in it. If we go
down to the part of the JavaScript interpreter,
that handles calling functions, we can run this
sampler web page and discover that what the
correct answer is, three and four has actually
becomes 888 and 999. As it turns out, this very
wrong answer is caused by a very simple bug.
Hopefully you ran a few of your own text cases
to narrow down the problem, but right here on
this line is the culprit. Our new environment –
the environment in which we evaluate the
statements of the function body, is the ENV
variable which comes from the call, ends the
value passed into ENV is actually environment
from which we call the function. If you recall
the parsing for our JavaScript functions, the first
element of the tuple is the strength function
which says that this represents a function. The
second is the parameters for the function. We
then have the function body what is just a
sequence of statements and then lastly we have
the environment for the function. This is the
parent from which the function was defined and
it’s actually environment in which we’re
supposed to executive the function. However,
with this code that’s not the case. We’re
executing the function; the environment from
what we call it, not from what it was defined. So
we need to fix that.
So I’ve defined a variable function environment,
which just grabs the fourth element or the third
index out of the tuple and instead of creating the
new environment as ENV, which is going to be
the function environment that we want. And
that’s it. The consequences of the bug are pretty
severe, but it’s really just what do we change,
10 characters, I mean, that’s just how these bugs
can be. It can be really hard to find that’s why
finding bugs is time consuming, difficult and
it’s a skill that you’re going to have to learn
because its just part of programming, you’re
going to make mistakes.